every Friday we are taking time to
answer your most pressing questions
about the coronavirus and this morning
with many states partially lifting
restrictions we're talking about how to
safely venture out in public big
question there this is despite the fact
that a recent poll found 67 percent of
Americans would be uncomfortable
visiting a clothing store and 78 percent
say they'd be uncomfortable eating in a
restaurant CBS News senior medical
correspondent dr. Tara Narula joins us
now to walk us through some of the
guidance the latest guidance anyhow so
as people go outside whether they're
going to a restaurant or a clothing
store or just taking a walk what
precautions should they take to keep
themselves safe well Tony it's true
we're all beginning to emerge from our
cocoon
but life as we know it is definitely
going to be different and it's important
that we take these precautions really
until we have herd immunity or we have a
vaccine so first and foremost it's going
to be important to try to keep that six
feet distance in mind when you're going
out and about and really minimize your
time and those crowded maybe poorly
ventilated spaces wearing a homemade or
cloth mask is still going to be helpful
given the rates of what we know are
asymptomatic trance transmission in
addition you want to practice all those
good hygiene things we've talked about
hand-washing sanitizer disinfecting
surfaces using your elbow to touch the
elevator door button the elevator button
and then you want to try to keep as
little contact as possible so online
banking telemedicine having your
pharmacy prescriptions delivered to your
home food delivery and even things like
Apple pay so you don't have to actually
exchange cash or get your credit card
out and then finally I know we're all
gonna be tempted to hug and kiss and
really get close to each other but you
are gonna want to continue the elbow
bump or the foot tap and and really
trying to keep your distance all right
we've got a viewer question from Laura
who is interested in knowing whether if
she and a friend are both wearing masks
and they're outside can they get within
six feet of one another for somewhat
normal interaction well that's a great
question and really the mask is still
going to be important in the sense that
again we know there's this asymptomatic
transmission of the virus
the mask is not airtight especially the
ones that people are wearing at home the
non n95 masks and so viruses can
essentially go around the mask or
through the mask or land on the mask and
so you can get infected and really what
they're meant for is preventing you from
infecting others with those large
droplets but it's really not a license
to break that six feet rule just because
you're both wearing masks all right we
also have a question here from Julie Ann
who emailed in to ask a question I have
as well is it safe to take your kids to
the park and then I would just add on to
that if they see other kids in the park
can you let them do what kids do get
together and have fun well we have two
kids and we've been taking them to the
park every single day you know kids need
that fresh air and exercise they should
be getting 60 minutes of physical
activity every day and the park is a
great place for that because usually it
is a large wide space where kids can
maintain distance from others so
important things to remember if you do
bring toys or things for your kids are
gonna wash them when you come home and
we were in the situation recently where
another family sort of wandered over and
started playing with the balls that our
kids were playing with and we really had
to say you know listen I think we really
need to keep a little bit of distance
right now so I don't think there's
anything wrong with being vocal about
that if that happens and and again you
want to avoid things like playgrounds
where there's a lot of touching of the
monkey bars and the swings so open wide
space in the park is the best idea away
from others all right and we've got a
related question actually from a viewer
named Amy related because so many
families including mine we are
sheltering in place but other families
are as well they have kids we have kids
can those two families that are both
sheltering get together safely for the
sake of the kids if nothing else well
it's it's understandable that people
want to get together and the issue is
really that you don't know where the
other family has been what they've been
touching who they've been interacting
with so just because you've been
sheltering in place we're not living in
a bubble and it doesn't mean that you're
not going to be exposed to the virus and
potentially be able to transmit the
virus so it is a good idea
to continue that separation as hard as
it
in fact even from New York we have the
most recent numbers showing that of the
last several days most of the
hospitalizations were coming from people
who were at home who were not travelling
and not working so that just goes to
tell you that shelter in place does not
mean you are immune from getting the
virus yeah that's a really good point
dr. taryn Narula thank you a great
guidance as always